[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE MICHELS: All
right, everybody.
Thank you so much for
coming to Talks at Google.
We have an amazing guest
for you today, Adam Braun.
Adam started an
organization in 2008
called Pencils of Promise,
which a lot of you
might have heard of.
They've gone all
around the world
and started schools in
impoverished regions.
They've started over
400 schools to date.
He's actually the
New York Times best
selling author of "The
Promise of a Pencil,"
and he recently just
started his newest venture,
which is incredibly exciting.
It's trying to basically up-end
the traditional college system
and end the cycle of debt,
teach students practical skills.
It's a one-year program.
It's really exciting,
and he's here,
and that's mainly what we're
going to be focused on.
Can't wait to have Adam speak.
He's a perfect
example of somebody
who kind of embarked on a
nontraditional path that's
purpose driven at a young age.
And he's going to talk about
where education is headed
and what MissionU's
place is in that.
And that's what I
just described--
his new his new venture.
So please join me in welcoming
Adam Braun to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM BRAUN: Thank you so much.
So as you heard, I spent
really the last decade
of my life focused on
education, both internationally
and now more so domestically.
And so I figured I'd walk you a
little bit through that journey
and open up today's talk with
a little bit more context,
in particular, on
MissionU, and then we
can dive into some questions and
then really open it up to a Q&A
with all of you.
So to begin with, this is
a community in rural Ghana.
Pencils of Promise
began in 2008.
I put $25 into a bank account
in hopes of building one school,
and that first school
was in rural Laos.
Over time, what I
saw was that not only
did I have a personal passion
for attempting and really
guiding, I think, communities,
in particular communities
of poverty in rural parts
of the developing world,
to enable their future
generations of children
to gain access to
better education.
But that idea really resonated
with a lot of people,
in particular, young
people across the country.
And so what started
in rural Laos
grew to Nicaragua and
Guatemala, eventually Ghana.
And this was a community that I
entered with some of our staff.
And what we saw was
that about 800 people
live in this community.
And this was considered the
school for the entire village.
So you can imagine, obviously,
these children were not
getting access to the
quality of education
that we would all want for them.
And with the support of actually
a school in the United States--
in Chicago--
that put together a
peer-to-peer fundraiser,
we were able to raise
the funds to go and work
with this community
directly to really transform
the lives of those children.
And it transformed
from this into this,
which is what a completed
a Pencil of Promise
school looks like.
And I spent a lot of time over
this last decade going, really,
not only around the country,
but around the world speaking
about this work, trying to
really galvanize others to get
involved in this process.
And fortunately,
the organization
has grown by leaps and bounds.
It's really found
tremendous success.
And the next step
for me in 2013 is
we started to approach what
felt like a very big milestone,
which was completing our
100th school, which actually
was in Ghana as well.
I decided to write
a book about it.
And that book was called
"The Promise of a Pencil."
What was really
important was actually
the subtitle of the book, which
is "how an ordinary person can
create extraordinary change."
And so as much as I felt
really inspired by the work
that we were taking
on, my real goal
was actually to help
other people figure out
how they could pursue
their sense of purpose
and their sense of passion.
And so the book is framed
around 30 very short chapters.
Each chapter is
titled with a mantra,
and those mantras were
really the guideposts for me
as I navigated the challenging
waters of figuring out
how do you build a global
organization from scratch,
in particular, starting
in late 2008 in New York,
which was an incredibly
challenging period.
And so that subtitle, "how
an ordinary person can
create extraordinary change,"
is what motivated me.
And I found myself on
many, many college campuses
around the country.
And as I would tell
this story, there
were certainly a subset of
people that would actively
get involved.
And they'd tell their friends,
they'd tell their family,
and as a result,
this organization
continued to grow
in recent years.
And as of today, we've
now built over 400 schools
around the world.
We have about 75,000
students in our programs.
And what started
with just $25 has now
turned into more
than $50 million
raised to support these
children around the world.
But as I went from
location to location
to location really speaking
about the value and virtue
of this work, what I found was
a common refrain on every type
of college campus
that I visited,
whether these were elite private
schools, community colleges
in Tennessee and Arizona,
large state schools,
non-elite private
schools, there was always
this significant
subset of students
that would come up to
me afterwards or ask
a question during Q&A.
And they'd say, Adam,
this is really great
what you're describing,
but I can't even
consider the type
of work that you're
describing because, one, I
have so much student debt
that the number-one
thing in my life
is trying to get out
of that student debt.
And then, two, I
don't actually have
any of the skills that
are going to help me
get the jobs that I'm seeking.
And I'm now hearing this as I
apply for internships and jobs.
And so I started to
do a lot of research
into some of these challenges.
And I deeply believe in
organizational focus.
And so Pencils of
Promise needed to stay
true to its core mission
to support children
in the developing world.
But there was a huge
personal transition for me
when I met my wife.
And at the time, you start to
fall in love with somebody,
you start planning
a life together,
and one of those
important conversations
is to figure out where you're
coming from financially.
And what was very clear to me
from really the first month
that we spent
together was that she
was from a very
loving family but one
without a lot of
financial means.
And they came to
this country when
she was nine from South Africa,
moved to the Boston area
in hopes of really building a
life of success and prosperity.
And if you're new to this
country, in particular
or you're of the working-class
or lower-income family, what's
the number-one thing that
every parent tells you
you should invest and
that you should focus on
to get a better life ahead?
Education, right?
And I think that's a dream
that we've really kind of sold
to generation after generation.
On my mother's side,
my grandfather actually
was part of the first wave
of individuals to get access
to free college in
the United States
through the GI Bill,
which was passed in 1944.
And it really started this
movement towards college
for all.
But my wife bought into
that, and she went to college
initially out of state, after
two years transferred back
in state to try and
reduce the cost.
And after three years
needed to leave school
before actually attaining that
bachelor's degree that she
was pursuing, because
the challenges were
so great financially.
And by the time that I
met her, her student debt
was at over $100,000 as a
result of these three years.
And it was absolutely crushing.
And eventually, as we
moved towards marriage,
I said you should
really consider
declaring full bankruptcy.
You should hopefully--
I know it's going to
destroy your credit,
but I have good credit.
We'll be OK as a couple.
And at least you'll be
out of this cage that
might keep you in poverty
throughout the rest
of your life.
And she said to me, Adam, that
sounds great but student debt
is the only debt in the United
States that you cannot declare
bankruptcy on.
And I remember-- you know, I
have a financial background,
started my career at Bain,
been working at hedge funds
since I was like 16.
I was like, that's not possible.
That's just impossible.
Let me talk to some
financial people
and help you get out of this.
And of course, she
was absolutely right,
and I was absolutely wrong.
And as soon as I really
discovered that, I think that
in, at least my mind, that's the
moment that MissionU was born,
that if we had a
societal injustice that
was this great, this profound,
and the one thing that
was supposed to enable the
people who needed to kind
of experience
social mobility most
was going to keep them
in those places or worse,
then we're creating a greater
and greater societal divide
between the classes,
which obviously leads us
to this huge political division
and all these other challenges
that we're now
facing as a country.
And so I said I need
to research this more.
And I'll show you a chart
that a friend of mine,
Neil Blumenthal, sent
me a few months ago.
Neil is the
co-founder and co-CEO
of Warby Parker and someone who
is also passionate about this,
because he's seeing
it on his team.
Some of the challenges of
finding work-ready talent,
especially out of undergrad.
And so this is the price
change in consumer goods
over the last 20 years or so.
And what you can see is that the
bottom, things like software,
toys, new cars, clothing,
et cetera, essentially
luxury consumer goods, have
actually drastically come down.
Much more people can access
them than ever before.
What you see at the very top
is that education has never
been more expensive.
And even more expensive
than traditional education
is college tuition.
It's risen more than essentially
any other incurred fee
that someone is going to
take on in their life.
As I started to dig further
and further into this, what
I realized was that
not only do you
see this huge
growth, the red line
in the cost of getting
an undergraduate degree,
but the blue line is
the average earnings
of a bachelor-degree holder
between the ages of 24 and 34.
And so that's
actually gone down.
And so what we have
is, one, this situation
where any person who's
entering college and has
to take on debt, that number is
just increasing and increasing.
And now it's becoming
oftentimes insurmountable.
Today's entering freshmen
will have on average
$50,000 of debt by the time
they graduate, if they graduate.
And only a much lower
percentage than we
actually anticipate graduate.
And then, two, they actually
don't have the skills
that they need.
About 3/4 believe
that their college
has failed to prepare
them for the real world.
And so there are
three macro shifts
that I observed in
really 2016 into 2017,
and now here we
are in 2018, that
would enable a very
new model for us
to really kind of recreate,
reinvent, and reinvigorate
this very oftentimes
averse-to-change space
of higher ed.
And so the first is
historically credentials
were really the
metric for success.
People just said, OK,
do you have a degree?
Yes, then you must be
skilled, because we
didn't have all this other
information on an individual.
You couldn't search
for them on Google.
You couldn't look up
their LinkedIn credentials
10 or 15 years ago.
So now seeing this shift over
to competency-based hiring,
in particular for
technical skills
you can just put a test
in front of somebody
and you can assess their
technical abilities.
And that's actually much
more important than perhaps
whether they have
a degree or not.
The second is that
historically tests were
the primary method of learning.
We did rote
memorization and then
after that rote
memorization, then
we just jumped into an exam,
and we regurgitated that,
and that was a
demonstration of learning.
And I think that what we are
seeing a radical shift to
is project-based learning,
where it's much more replicable
to put together a
group of projects
that a person actually
navigates through in a group.
And that in itself is a
lot more demonstrative
of what we actually
experience in the real world,
in our work context.
And then the third is that in
2012, we saw the rise of MOOCs
like Coursera and Udacity.
There was this huge
belief that we're
going to have the best
professor in the world.
He's going to get 15,000
people, and that's
going to solve the
challenges of education.
And what we're seeing is that
the vast majority of people
don't actually
complete those courses.
It's less than 5%.
Most of us are not
considered autodidacts,
that we can teach ourselves
and have that motivation
and accountability to
complete one of those courses.
And so what we are
able to do, though,
is work very effectively in
online cohorts when it's live,
synchronous instruction.
When there is an instructor,
a world-class expert
in something, with a
small group and we're
held accountable to those
around us on the screen,
and it's done live, that's
actually very, very powerful.
And we've seen a few models
involved in that space that
are able to demonstrate that.
And really, this started 2016.
I moved from New York, after
replacing myself as CEO
at Pencils of Promise,
out to the Bay Area
to focus on building
a college alternative
for the 21st century, really
reinventing the model of what
higher education
can and should look
like if you started from today.
And so I'll show
you a quick video.
It features some really
extraordinary people
that have gotten behind
what we're doing,
and it walks you a little
bit through why this works
and how it works.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PLAYBACK ENDED]
ADAM BRAUN: So
MissionU, in essence,
is this one-year program that
focuses on real-world skills.
And one of the things
that we've certainly seen
is that it's not enough just
to teach hard technical skills,
but people that
really thrive actually
possess this whole
wealth of soft skills--
effective collaboration,
critical thinking abilities,
effective communication,
both in written,
whether it's email or building
presentations or in person.
And so we also
thought about, what
is an actual viable revenue
model for a modern institution
that aligns itself with the
outcomes and the aspirations
of their students from day one?
And so what we decided was that
before any student ever paid us
a dollar of tuition,
we would have
to demonstrate to them that
they had achieved success, which
is really the exact
opposite of what
happens on a traditional
college today, right?
You take out these big
loans, you pay the school,
and then you kind of hope
for the best, that you end up
with a job afterwards.
But their commitment
essentially ends
when you walk out
their door, and that's
when they usually reach out in
order to ask for a donation.
How many people have
gotten that solicitation
from their alma mater?
Probably all of us.
And so what we decided was that
when someone got in MissionU,
we would charge them
absolutely no tuition upfront.
And instead, we
would invest in them
throughout the course of
their entire year at MissionU.
And at the end of that
year, only if and when
they were making at
least $50,000 or more,
they would contribute
back 15% of their income
for three years.
And then that would be the
end of their obligation.
And so it's an entirely
outcomes-based model.
And we said, so when it comes
to designing curriculum,
most colleges kind
of oftentimes are
very separated from
the business world.
We said we should
absolutely partner
with the business world.
This is what students want.
91% of today's freshmen say
they're going to college
to get a better job.
And so before we ever
started recruiting students,
we were speaking to
world-class companies.
And they deeply advised
us on curriculum.
Everything that we
teach our students
goes through the lens
of employer partners
evaluating, assessing,
and advising.
The second is we
would create content
so we have guest speakers
nonstop for our students.
They oftentimes go on
site to actual companies
to get that
real-world experience.
So all of our employer
partners get first cut
at this incredible
pipeline of talent.
And as of now, these
partners include companies
like Spotify, Lyft, Uber,
Warby Parker, Casper,
Harry's, et cetera,
with a bunch more
to be announced shortly, and
hopefully Google at some point
as well.
And so what I figured
would actually be helpful
is to walk you
through a little bit
of how we've integrated
Google's technology being
here on campus.
You guys have been an
incredible, incredible provider
of the technology that actually
powers a lot of our student
experience.
We use blended learning.
We think that's really the
future of education, which
is a hybrid of
both online, which
is live primarily for our
students, as well as in person.
We think that a lot of students
can learn very well online,
in particular technical
skills, but those soft skills
and those relationships that you
create with your cohort mates
really have to be
facilitated in person.
So our students come together
at minimum every other week.
A lot of them actually
live together,
because you have to live within
50 miles of your cohort city.
And then finally,
I figured I'd just
share a little bit of
what our year looks like.
The first trimester
is a deep dive
into what we consider
foundational skills,
a mix of both hard
skills and soft skills,
a lot of things that come out
of Stanford on the soft skill
and holistic development side,
a lot of things that come out
of places like Bain where I
started my career, as well
as some of the
instruction from top data
scientists and our
instructors, as well as
advisors come from places like
Harvard and Stanford and MIT.
Second trimester is a
deep dive into your major.
Right now we offer one, which
is data analytics and business
intelligence.
Over time, we'll
layer in many more.
And then the final
trimester is actually
real-world work experience,
either internships,
fellowships, or
consulting projects,
so that they can complete the
year with the actual competency
that they want to enter
the workforce with.
So with that, I guess
we'll kind of dive
into a little bit
of a conversation.
But if anybody wants to
follow up or get involved
in any capacity, this
is just my email,
and I'll leave it
up there as we chat.
JESSE MICHELS: Cool.
Thanks, Adam.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSE MICHELS: Awesome.
Really appreciate you being
here and for the Google plug.
So I want to kind of just
bring it back for a second
and just provide a little bit
of context for the audience.
Talk about your childhood.
You talked about the inflection
point between Pencils
of Promise and MissionU.
I'd love to hear you
focus on the inflection
point between the
kind of overachieving
typical path of hedge fund,
Bain, to Pencils of Promise.
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
I had a good childhood,
I mean, a great one.
My parents are amazing.
So now I have 14-month-old
twins at home.
And so my parents have
suddenly never become smarter
in my life, and I've
never gone to them
for more advice than since
becoming a parent myself.
But they're both very loving.
My dad's an immigrant,
came here when he was
three, a child of two
Holocaust survivors.
And my mother's
father passed away
when she was quite
young, when she was 11.
And so I think that even though
we had this great upbringing--
my dad's a dentist, my
mom's an orthodontist--
and so I don't think that
we felt any sense of, hey,
we're impoverished.
But I'd look around in
the town that we grew up
in, which is
Greenwich, Connecticut,
and there were certainly people
with way more than what we had.
And so I was always aware
of that juxtaposition
that we were fine, but there
was a lot more to be achieved.
But I think having
the recognition
that your grandparents
lost everything,
including family members
and every possession
in the Holocaust, there
was this kind of mentality,
I guess, just ingrained
in us, this kind
of like immigrant
mentality of you've
got to work for
everything that you're
going to go out and achieve.
And so in the
teenage mind, it was
go out and make a lot of
money and hedge funds,
and the world of finance was
the best way to accomplish that.
And so that was
the path I was on.
But when I was 21, I
went on Semester at Sea
and just had this series of
life-changing experiences
through exposure to
the developing world.
And I realized the actual
purpose for my life
is to try and bring as much
positivity and well-being
into the world as I
can and enabling others
to reach their full potential,
which education I believe
does most, is the path that
I've pursued since then.
JESSE MICHELS: And how would
you advise somebody who's maybe
in that situation,
where they're kind
of on the linear path toward
success, to break out of it?
Is it kind of getting
out there and seeing
the undeveloped world?
ADAM BRAUN: You know,
my advice has always
been that true
self-discovery begins
where your comfort zone ends.
And so the surest way
to get to that place
where you feel most
alive or you have
this deep ingrained
sense of purpose
is by leaving your
current comfort zone.
And for some, it's physical
relocation-- go traveling.
You go on a trip to a kind
of remote part of the world.
But I don't think
that's necessary.
In other capacities, it's
changing the relationships
around you.
It's changing what your
day-to-day actual routine looks
like, exposure to new
hobbies that you never
thought that you'd
actually be interested in.
All of those things, I
think, help us get unstuck
from what we are and what
people and society and norms
dictate we're supposed to
be, into who we truly are.
And then the final
thing is I think
you can just learn from the
template of others before you.
And so that means reading books.
I listen to a ton of podcasts.
And a lot of those podcasts
are just interviews.
On my way here today, I was
listening to an interview
with the founder of Patagonia.
And it was just so
inspiring for me
over the last hour or so hearing
how different this person's
path was and the decisions
that he's made historically.
And it helped me
reframe the way that I
might want to dictate some
of the decisions in my life
as well.
JESSE MICHELS: And I want to
touch on Pencils of Promise
briefly.
I want to focus
on MissionU today,
but where is Pencils
of Promise at?
How involved are you and what's
the plan for it going forward?
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
So Pencils of Promise is about
130 full-time staff globally,
operating in four different
countries, New York
being the headquarter, but
the vast majority of our staff
is from the countries
in which they work.
They're Ghanaian, they're
Lao, they're Guatemalan.
We do have 20
schools in Nicaragua
that we built originally.
We decided not to
continue expanding there.
So we support that through
a partnership on the ground.
We had our single biggest
growth ever in 2017,
which is hugely exciting.
And my role is founder
and board emeritus,
which means that I'm
still involved but not
on a day-to-day active basis.
Decisions don't need to
go through me in order
to be made and executed.
But I tend to be
kind of the lightning
rod for inbound interest.
People will read the book,
and they'll reach out,
and then I can funnel
those relationships
to the organization as the
host of our annual gala, which
this past year raised over
$2 million in a night.
So I'm still very
involved, but not
on a day-to-day, full-time
role, whereas most
of my day-to-day
thinking is on MissionU.
JESSE MICHELS: We
have over $1 trillion
in student debt in this country.
It might be--
ADAM BRAUN: $1.4 trillion.
JESSE MICHELS: $1.4
trillion, which is crazy.
I remember reading a blog post,
maybe in 2008 or '09 by Mark
Cuban, actually talking-- kind
of comparing student debt issue
to the housing bubble, saying
we have an education bubble,
because students literally
are taking out all this money,
and they can't flip
it for a profit,
just like you would flip
a home for a profit.
ADAM BRAUN: Yep.
JESSE MICHELS: How exactly
is MissionU solving this?
ADAM BRAUN: From spending
all the time focused
on international
education, one thing
that I've really
seen and absorbed
is that in order to
create systemic change,
you need two things to happen.
The first is, you
need innovation.
And that innovation,
if you've read
Clayton Christensen's
"Innovator's Dilemma,"
it occurs on the fringes.
It's not mainstream.
It's kind of these outside
smaller players that
start out really small,
and they're so small,
and they're working
on something so unique
that your large incumbents
literally don't even
pay attention, even though
if they had replicated,
they could have squashed them.
And what oftentimes
occurs in systemic change
is that as that
innovator on the fringe
gets a demonstration of
success, what you actually need
is widespread policy
adoption and advocacy that
leads to a scaled impact.
And so my goal, in particular
when it comes to MissionU,
is for us to be that innovator
on the fringe that demonstrates
success and then
eventually has policy
adoption at the national level.
And then essentially what the
US does, a lot of countries
obviously follow.
So a small example
would be the fact
that we're using 100%
income share agreement
rather than traditional tuition.
The fact that we're doing that
is putting a lot of pressure
on traditional
colleges to respond.
And my hope is, I
don't expect to see
every college be 100% IRA--
Income Share Agreement--
but what I do expect to see
is for colleges to
be expected to start
to have some skin in
the game and eventually
for policy to
actually mandate that,
for students not to be required
to pay back until they reach
a certain threshold,
which is actually
the national policy in
countries like Australia,
as well as this blended learning
model to be demonstrated
as a proof one by us.
There are other companies
that are doing it and doing it
with great success,
and for then that
to get adopted by a
lot of the mainstream
incumbents as well as policy.
JESSE MICHELS: Now,
you started out
with Pencils of Promise kind
of focusing on accessibility
and getting as many students
around the world educated
as possible.
Peter Thiel talks about the
current college education
system, and he says it's
almost like a nightclub,
like if you expand it
and allow more people in,
they'll be very angry
because basically their bread
and butter is prestige.
ADAM BRAUN: Exclusivity.
JESSE MICHELS: Exactly.
Exclusivity.
So how do you reconcile those
two things, kind of it's
the social credential
where prestigious
may be semi-important,
along with accessibility
and reaching as many
people as possible?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
So this is a big thing for us,
and it's currently a challenge
that we're addressing
through scale.
So we launched March 2017.
We said we're open.
This is MissionU.
No one really had any
public exposure to it.
We asked everyone that knew
about it to not talk about it
until we were ready to launch.
We launched March 21, 2017,
and we said this is MissionU.
You can apply as of today.
And we spent no money on
any form of paid marketing.
And we said we just want to
see organically what happens.
I did interviews and podcasts
and stuff and prospected up.
But we did no
targeted marketing.
So we allowed the message
to spread to the places
where it might spread naturally.
And we said, we have
25 spots per cohort.
We'll just see how
many people apply.
And we had 4,700 applicants
for the first 25 spots
in about a 2 and
1/2 month period.
And we said, oh, my gosh.
There's some lightning
in a bottle here.
And our goal is not to be the
most exclusive selective higher
education program in
the country, which
statistically we are right now.
We have essentially a
0.5% acceptance rate.
We don't want to be that,
but we are at the moment.
So we said, one, we
need to go out and raise
more capital so we can
offer additional cohorts.
We don't want to
change the cohort size.
We think about 25 is the
best number for people
to build those tight
relationships, to have
the right ratio to instructors.
But we need to have
additional times in the year
when people could apply,
concurrently launch
cohorts at the same
time in the same cities,
expand to new cities, as
well as offer new majors.
So we went out, we raised
another round of capital
from some incredible
people, and then
we opened up
admissions for January.
We said, OK, you can
apply for January.
And we had 5,500 people
apply for those spots,
and now we're running
admissions for May.
And so again we
acknowledge that this
is a real challenge
in higher ed,
and our goal is to try and scale
quickly to serve that need.
But at the same time,
we want to create
a truly world-class,
high-quality experience
for every student.
And we know that we need to
start slowly and test out
this model.
And once it's really tightly
refined on the curricular side,
on the student
experience side, then
scale really, really rapidly.
I mean, our goal is to serve
tens of thousands of students,
ideally be larger than any
current college in the country.
JESSE MICHELS: Awesome.
What does a real-world
approach mean?
You guys talk about teaching
practical skills, as opposed
to maybe more theoretical ones.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
So first of all, it means having
a really tight pulse on what's
happening in industry.
So designing and building
curriculum in a vacuum,
having to go through a three to
four-year accreditation process
and then saying
you should go learn
this, as all of you,
I'm sure, experience
on a day-to-day basis here
at a place like Google,
is going to leave you well
behind what's actually needed
to solve the needs of industry.
So part of it is having these
deep relationships with folks
at companies to understand
what's needed to actually hit
the ground running.
The second is, I think,
a profound acknowledgment
that you need to bring that
real world into the curricular
design.
And so, as I mentioned,
we have our--
I went to a great college,
and I loved my experience.
But I don't think more than
once did I ever get exposure
to a public speaker who came
in and addressed a class
that I was in that actually
was working at a company.
It was so rare.
And so for our
students, last week
the global head of artist
marketing at Spotify
spent an hour just with
a group of 30 students.
And that's like
on a weekly basis,
a top-tier person comes
in and addresses them.
But then the second is
actually teaching them
things that are going to
be applicable to getting
a great job, to navigating
their personal life as well.
So we teach personal finance.
How many people here
got a deep introduction
to personal finance,
how you actually
navigate your financial
scenario once you
leave the bounds of your
educational experience?
Everyone's nodding
their head no.
So things like that.
We have a class
that we call Success
By Design, which is
really about finding
your internal
happiness, where you
want to point your
compass in life, and why.
All of those
things, I think, are
applicable to a
real-world context.
And then finally,
our students work
on projects that are based
on real-world scenarios.
So we'll get dummy data
from real companies that
are facing a real challenge.
Our students will work through
that, produce a final project.
And then that
after they ship it,
they can, one, publicly present
it as part of their portfolio,
but oftentimes they
actually get to present it
to somebody who's working
on that real project
at that real company.
And they get that
cycle of feedback.
And then the final part is
just the back third of the year
is actually working full time at
a great company or organization
and then getting additional
curricular support from us
throughout that process.
JESSE MICHELS: Yeah, one of the
perks we have here at Google
is we get to speak to
financial advisors,
and I think this was my
first job out of school,
and I didn't know anything.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
JESSE MICHELS: And I think most
people don't know anything.
ADAM BRAUN: Right.
JESSE MICHELS: They don't
know what a 401(k) is.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
One of the things that
we teach our students
is salary negotiation.
And I remember sitting
with a reporter
from a major media
company explaining that.
And she was in her mid-thirties
and she said, jeez,
I wish I got that.
And so we think it's important.
And our students
range from 18 to 39.
Some of them have transferred
in from top-tier colleges.
Some of them have
bachelor's degrees.
Most of them have some type
of college but not BA yet
and are looking
out and saying, why
would I take on
this much more debt
to get this piece of
paper that isn't actually
going to be of greatest value,
whereas MissionU will be.
JESSE MICHELS: There seems to
be a special interest right now
on learning how to learn.
That's actually the most popular
course on Coursera right now.
Barbara Oakley teaches it.
Do you guys incorporate the most
recent neuroscientific findings
and findings about
just how to learn
and how cognition
happens in MissionU?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
This is the obsession
of my co-founder, Mike.
So Mike's our Chief
Product Officer,
and he oversees both
curriculum and technologies
and work with software
engineer as well.
So all this stuff that
you were seeing on Google,
he's overseeing and designing
with Jen, who you heard.
And yeah, if you saw the
slack channels of our team,
like you would just think
these people are the biggest
education nerds in the world.
So yeah, we obsess and kind
of geek out over that stuff.
And then we have
incredible advisors
like Dr. Tony Wagner from
Harvard or Fern Mandelbaum
from the lecture at Stanford.
And so we're constantly kind
of digging into the latest
learning science.
Part of that applies into
how the actual structure
of the program looks.
So for example, we tell
every student that--
so one thing that I'll
share is I actually call
every student when they get in.
So the actual
admissions acceptance
is me calling them
kind of as a surprise,
and they always answer and
say, hi, who's calling?
And I say it's Adam Braun.
I'm from MissionU, and then
they're like, oh, uh, hi.
How's it going?
What's up?
And then I'll say
how's your day?
And they say it's
good, and I'll say,
OK well, hopefully
it's a lot better,
because I wanted to share
with you that you got in.
And they're all excited.
And then I kind of
walk them through,
hey, here's the next steps.
Here is the orientation date.
We'll send you an email and
repeat a lot of this stuff
so you have it in writing.
But I want to get them
comfortable with a couple
of the high-level details.
And one thing I share is that
you can work a part-time job
while you're going
through our program,
but you can't exceed
20 hours a week.
And that's grounded
in learning science
that shows that if you exceed
20 hours a week of a job
while you're trying to focus on
a primary academic commitment,
your success in that program
really falls off the map.
So things like that
are applicable for us.
JESSE MICHELS: And
kind of reconciling
teaching practical skills
and emphasizing that
with just a liberal arts
education to begin with,
I can imagine where you
kind of fall on that.
But there are people
like Fareed Zakaria
who talk about the
loss of liberal arts
education in the country.
I went to Columbia,
and I'm still
trying to figure out whether
reading Plato helps me
every day.
But yeah, where do
you stand on that?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, my belief
on this is very firm.
I think there is
tremendous value
in the ideals behind a
liberal arts education.
So self-discovery, critical
thinking, reasoning, morality,
all of these things are
really, really essential
as part of a
formative education.
The problem is, those things
are actually not taught
in a meaningful capacity in the
vast majority of liberal arts
programs in this country.
What liberal arts
has kind of become
is general education,
where you're just
asked to read a series of
texts and suddenly you're
supposed to be expected
to achieve these things.
So some schools do
it well but very few.
The two places that I think
that it's best achieved
are through two courses
that are taught at Stanford.
One is called
Designing Your Life.
It's the most popular class
in undergrad at Stanford.
And then the second is called
interpersonal dynamics, taught
at Stanford GSP, but
known as Touchy-Feely.
And if anyone here has
gone to GSP or know
someone that's gone
GSP, this is the course
that they will say is the most
transformative in their life.
And so we actually
have former lecturers
from those two courses who are
full time on staff in MissionU.
And our students go
through something
that is very, very similar.
We call it iLabs or similar
to the T groups there.
And when you mix that with
the hard technical skills,
that's actually when
you create a really
profound transformation
in an individual.
So I think it's important
that we incorporate
the ideals of a liberal
arts but that you mix it
with the actual hard and soft
skills that will help somebody
get a job to pay back
the debt that they've
taken on, if they gone to
a traditional liberal arts
school.
And we really seek to
blend that at MissionU.
JESSE MICHELS: So
is that really how
you stay away from being
considered like a trade school?
Because there are a lot
of schools out there
that are like, I don't
like my career right now,
and so I'll switch
and go to this school.
And then it's just
kind of a pivot.
ADAM BRAUN: Right.
JESSE MICHELS: Is that
how you kind of stray away
from that, by having
these kind of structures?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, I
think what we've seen
is there's a lot of schools
that are out there that
are very effective at helping
you get into a new industry
and lock in a first job.
That's not our goal.
Our students only
send us $1 if they're
successful not only
in getting the job,
but they need to be successful
for three-plus years.
And so we want to prepare
them for an extraordinary life
and career ahead.
And part of that is learning
this hard technical skill,
but actually a
much bigger part is
the soft skills and that
holistic self-development.
And if you spoke to any
student that's at MissionU,
they'll say that
they needed one to be
able to succeed in the
other, that when they really
hit that kind of sticking
point in learning Python or SQL
or Excel modeling, it's actually
the group discussion that
will happen in iLab
that gives them
the confidence and
the self-awareness
to be able to progress
through those challenges.
JESSE MICHELS: Do you have
kind of like a 10-year game
plan for MissionU?
It seems like
right now you might
be going kind of
the Uber-Tesla model
where you start kind of premium
and then you kind of widen out.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
JESSE MICHELS: What's the plan?
So one, Pencil of Promise
is in its 10th year.
And if you would have told
me at the beginning when
I was trying to build
one school and riding
my motorbike with the
backpack in rural Alps
by myself that this year
we'd likely break ground
on our 500th school, I would
have said that's insane.
And so I think it's challenging
to project 10 years out.
That said, the
ambition is certainly
within 10 years for us to
be in dozens of cities.
Again, everyone
lives within 50 miles
so they can come
together frequently.
But the 50-mile radius
allows for more affordability
than just having to be
close to a downtown campus.
So we'll be in dozens of cities.
We'll be offering, I would
imagine, 10-plus majors.
And I think 10 years from
now, parents and children
will essentially
look at MissionU,
and I assume others
will follow our lead
and create similar
types of programs.
And it will be a
real consideration
for every student that
is considering college,
whether they're fresh
out of high school,
mid-career, working
adult, is do I
go to one of these
traditional four
to six-years that's
a little bit outdated
or do I go through
something like a MissionU?
And it will just be part of the
landscape of higher education.
JESSE MICHELS: And
are you convinced
that going forward a classroom
is the best kind of medium
or setting to learn?
ADAM BRAUN: I think it depends
on how you define a classroom.
So a classroom does
not need to have
four physical walls around it.
If I showed you the
engagement of our students,
it looks like a Brady
Bunch style set of screens.
Our admissions process
actually replicates that
through a group challenge, where
we have total strangers design
actually on a Google Drive.
We give them an
ambiguous challenge,
and then they actually build a
presentation in Google Sheets
together in 45 minutes and
present it to our staff.
And we record the whole thing on
Zoom and Go and watch it back.
And so I think that, to me,
is a version of a classroom.
What I would say is a medium
through which individuals
are able to communicate in
a live, synchronous manner
with intimacy and honesty
is the best way to learn.
It's certainly better
than doing it by yourself,
unless you have a direct tutor.
So some type of
human engagement.
And that can be a classroom of
sorts, you and another person,
and I don't think that large
lecture halls are the way
to do it.
But I do think that
there's tremendous power
in these small group
cohort-based formats,
in particular, behind a
screen where everything
is being recorded and where
you truly feel accountable.
JESSE MICHELS: I want to move
on to you briefly before we
open it up to Q&A. Are there
habits or philosophies that
help you just perform at
a high level every day?
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
This has evolved.
In my 20s, it was like just
putting as much work as I can
and try and respond to
everything as fast as I can
and make the most of
every opportunity.
And like I'll sleep
when I'm dead.
That was kind of my approach.
I think now in my 30s and
with a wife and two kids,
I've really learned
the value of self-care.
And so for example, if
I work out consistently
in a given week--
I mountain bike and
I play basketball--
then I actually perform
much better in the office.
If I'm able to meditate
for 10 to 15 minutes
before the babies are up
and then my house like goes
into all hell breaking
loose, then I feel much more
grounded throughout the day.
I use an app called Captio,
which allows me to just send
quick notes to myself.
And my inbox tends
to be my to-do list.
And so I try and practice
Inbox Zero or some form of it.
And then the other, I think,
is just treating people the way
that you would
want to be treated.
Are you building a culture that
really values people as people,
not just as numbers
on your Excel
sheet of headcount
roadmaps or your org chart?
And really focus on
growing those people
into the best-performing
individuals
that they can and the
best people that they can
leads to a really rewarding
work environment and something
that you're excited to
going into every day.
JESSE MICHELS: Nice.
What's your why?
What's the thing
that drives you?
ADAM BRAUN: You know,
my why is quite simply
that by every statistical
measure, I shouldn't be here.
My grandparents were
meant to pass away
in those concentration camps.
If anyone's read my book,
on "Semester At Sea,"
my cruise ship was hit by a
60-foot rogue wave 800 miles
from land, and we had this
Titanicesque experience where I
was supposed to die that
day and somehow I didn't.
And so I genuinely
feel like this life
for me is one in a trillion.
And so I need to do everything
that I can to honor that
and both leave the
most positive mark
that I can on as many
people as possible.
And now as a new father, I
realize that at the same time
I have to balance
that with the fact
that the greatest mark that
I can leave on the world
is producing great children
and being a great husband
and great father and sibling.
So those are the
two things for me--
you know, this kind
of big scaled ambition
with this very
small one that I'm
most happy when I'm just
hanging out with my kids
in their little room.
JESSE MICHELS: Do you
have mentors or role
models who've really helped you
and affected you throughout?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
I have a bunch of mentors that
I've gathered over the years.
One of them is a guy named
Ray Chambers, who is probably
most responsible in the world
for eradication of malaria,
became a billionaire, really
started the leveraged buyout
space.
And I was at lunch at one
point with a guy named
Randall Lane, who is the
Editor in Chief of Forbes.
And he told me that
maybe 15 or 20 years--
I can't remember how long-- but
he was not the editor in chief,
but he was running the Forbes
400 list as his function
at the company.
And Ray Chambers
was on the list,
and he got a call the next
day after it came out,
and this guy said how
do I get off the list?
I don't want to be on it.
And he said, well, you
either have to lose the money
or give it away, but
we're going to report it
if you're that wealthy.
He said, all right.
I'll be off by next year.
And he committed his life
to humanitarian work.
And so he's been an
incredible mentor.
And then certainly
my family members--
my dad, my mom, my
sister, my brother,
they're the people,
as well as my wife,
that I talk to most
about these decisions.
JESSE MICHELS: Speaking
of your family,
you have a very
high-achieving family.
Adam's brother actually
manages Justin Bieber,
among many other artists.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
A lot of people.
Kanye and a lot of people.
JESSE MICHELS: That's right.
Do you ever get competitive
with Scooter about anything?
You guys couldn't have
taken more different paths.
You're both very
impressive people,
but do you ever get
competitive with him?
ADAM BRAUN: You know, as kids
we were super competitive.
I think by the time we both hit
our kind of mid to late 20s,
we realized that we
were just operating
in such different spaces.
And the best thing
that we could do
is just be unbelievably
proud of one another
and try and support each other.
I think if you went to a
Saturday morning basketball
game where we're playing
on opposite teams,
you would see us
pretty competitive.
But in most things, we just try
and support one another as much
as we can.
JESSE MICHELS: Awesome.
Do you guys have any questions?
Let's open it up for Q&A.
And if you do, please
go to that mic right over there.
AUDIENCE: I resonated with
a lot of what you said.
Thanks for speaking.
I was wondering if
you wouldn't mind
sharing with us
some things that you
tried or thought that might work
but ended up not working out.
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
At Pencils of Promise,
Nicaragua was the second country
that we tried to expand into,
and I built a partnership
with an organization there.
They kind of showed me
the lay of the land.
We sent a small team
down, and it ultimately
wasn't successful
for two reasons.
The first was the government
was incredibly challenging.
We need to work with
supportive governments,
because we build public schools.
The second, though, was
we did this deep analysis,
and the population
density was very low,
and the cost of
materials was very high.
So what we saw was it
was two to 3 X more
expensive to impact the same
number of lives in that country
than it was in the
other eventually
three to four other countries
where we were working.
And that was really
tough, right?
You start in a country, you
actually make a commitment,
you build 20
schools, and then you
have to say we're not going to
continue to expand and build
our own teams there.
That was really hard.
But I think it forced an
organizational discipline
at Pencils of Promise for sure.
With MissionU, anyone
who saw our pitch deck
before there was even a
company, when it was just
like a seed of an
idea, would tell you
that the way it looks today
is remarkably similar.
There's only been one
meaningful change,
and that's that
originally we said we're
going to have four quarters.
And those quarters
were going to be
hard skills in
the first quarter,
soft skills in the second,
technical in the third,
and then real world
in the fourth.
And we realized right
away that you actually
can't divorce hard
skills from soft skills,
that they need to be
taught in conjunction.
And so we moved over
to a trimester model,
where that first trimester is
a deep dive on the foundation.
And so a lot of it is
like that lean kind
of mentality, the
test and iterate
and get feedback
from your consumers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks so much for coming.
It's a very
inspiring talk, and I
think this MissionU concept
is a really strong one.
So I guess my
general question is,
this problem of
crushing student debt
seems to be a uniquely
American problem.
I was wondering if you,
during your research,
you looked at other countries
and maybe could take away
something like
either boring stuff
that you could incorporate into
MissionU or are there any--
this is sort of a private-sector
solution to education problem,
and is there any role
for the US government
that could lead to better
reforming the education system
or solving the
problem that exists?
ADAM BRAUN: Absolutely.
So right now, there's
a new bill that's
being formed that's probably the
most significant restructuring
of higher education funding
in the last 40 years.
So they're overhauling
essentially
the Higher Education Act.
And there's some stuff in
there that I agree with,
there's some stuff that I don't.
But I think directionally,
it's actually
a move in the right direction.
So one of the
things is the reason
that we're in the
position that we're in
is a series of factors.
But one of the important ones
that the government has enabled
is that an individual
can essentially
take out an unlimited
line of credit
at a very young age without
any demonstrated capacity
to be able to pay that back.
And we have this society
that's kind of encouraged
through just societal
norms and expectations
that you should do that.
And so one thing that's
happened as a result
is that there is no
market force that's
creating downward pressure on
how much colleges can charge
or any accountability to
the value of that college
relative to the cost.
So for example, I can think
of many not very good colleges
that have terrible outcomes
that charge the same amount
as a school like Harvard.
And so that's like me being a
car salesman and saying to you,
here's this Lamborghini
for $200,000
or you can get this really
crappy old beat-up car
that's actually not
going to drive very well,
but that's $200,000 as well.
And you should buy this one too.
So I think that the
government needs to,
one, hold schools
accountable to outcomes.
And the best way to do
that is through skin
in the game, some type of income
share based on student success.
The second is to actually
realistically put
a limit on how much
a student can borrow.
And what I think
that will lead to
is colleges bringing
their prices down.
And the result of that
is that a lot of colleges
are going to go out of
business, because they have
unsustainable business models.
And that's actually, I
think, a very good thing.
We need to have market
forces in place that
remove bad actors that
are putting students
in positions of peril.
And just because you're
a nonprofit college
doesn't mean you're
actually helping people.
And there's a lot that are
actually hurting people.
So skin in the game,
capping total amounts
that students can take
out, and then the third
is transparency as to how much
it's actually going to cost.
It's very hard if you're
an 18, 19, 40-year-old,
and you're applying to
college to actually get
the clear information
on how much
it's eventually
going to cost you
as well as the outcomes
data of those colleges.
It's very convoluted.
They hide it.
And Congress needs to
really move forward
with an effort to ensure greater
transparency in the space.
AUDIENCE: It seems like there
would be a lot of forces that
would kind of be operating
against those kind of reforms,
like some of the colleges are at
risk of going out of business,
it's--
ADAM BRAUN: Definitely.
It's challenging,
because you have
one of the most entrenched
systems in our culture
as well as our capital
allocation in the country.
But what it's led to
is a position that's
completely unsustainable.
I read a report from
the Brookings Institute,
which is as nonpartisan,
objective, and well researched
as possible, that came out
last week that projected
that 40% of today's
college students
will default on
their loans by 2030.
I mean, it's insane.
So we need to have some type
of really meaningful change.
And as an entrepreneur, I
look at problems like this
and I say, if not me, then who?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the presentation.
I think the problem that
MissionU solves which
is about how to actually deliver
education in a system which
is not exactly built up
for the huge population
is probably going to apply
for the kind of countries
in which Pencils for
Promise operates in.
So do you see how technology
as a medium for instruction
can be actually scaled to
developing countries and--
ADAM BRAUN: Oh, yeah.
100%.
AUDIENCE: Just
finish my question.
And what exactly
are the challenges
that are preventing it
from happening as of today?
ADAM BRAUN: OK.
So great question.
One, when I talk about
that 10-year vision,
when I say we'll be in dozens
of cities around the world,
many of them should
be international.
So 18% of our applicants
are international.
You have to have a
visa to work in the US,
because we need to recuperate
our investment in you
through livable wages.
And so we can't take those
students on currently.
But we've had applicants from
dozens of other countries.
I recently gave a talk
in Singapore about this.
And the main question from
all these representatives
of the different countries was
how soon can this come here?
And so we certainly have
ambitions to scale globally.
I think right now,
part of the challenge
is the ability to deliver
live synchronous education
over low bandwidth internet.
But that's increasing
exponentially every single day.
And so I actually spent
a full year in 2015--
I was leading the largest
digital initiative
called the global Education
Platform for the UN Special
Envoy for Education, which is
Gordon Brown, the former Prime
Minister of the UK.
And in that year, what I
spent observing and seeing
was this huge proliferation of
mobile across the developing
world.
And so what I would
see at scale is
people being able to actually
have these experiences
on mobile in the
types of environments
where Pencils of Promise
has historically worked.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Terry.
I'm from China.
We are facing the same issue
in China, if it's not worse.
So I am truly
inspired by your talk
today, and thank
you for sharing.
You do great work.
My question is simple.
If that model
works for MissionU,
do you think it might work
for high school as well?
Because I see no point
now, if we go to college,
pay expensive tuition
and learn nothing.
But high school is preparing
for that entry examination
and for nothing, that's
four years likely wasted.
So maybe we can just start
younger and without any time
and inject hope in
these children's eyes.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
I think our curricular
approach certainly
can be adopted at the
high school level.
I don't know about the
income share agreement,
because some people do
want to work directly
at the end of high school.
But I think the curricular
approach certainly
can be adopted by public
and private schools.
The kind of product-based
and certainly
the blended learning,
the technology
can and should be used
in that capacity as well.
AUDIENCE: And then one
more piece, if I may.
JESSE MICHELS: Go for it.
AUDIENCE: If the compensation,
I mean all the payback part,
is not only measured
by the income,
what else it could be for
your success in the school?
ADAM BRAUN: For us, there's also
what we would consider NPS, so
Net Promoter Score.
That's actually just as
critical in our minds.
We need to create an environment
in which our students are
the single greatest
evangelists of our program.
And eventually they
become really the stewards
for additional innovation
within education.
It's what you've seen with
Teach for America, for example,
is they've certainly
seen success.
They've also had controversy
but directionally incredible
success.
And not only the success
within the schools
in which they have taught,
but their alums have
gone out and become stewards
for an incredible amount
of new initiatives that have
had a truly global impact.
And that, for us, is absolutely
critical for long-term success.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
ADAM BRAUN: Thank you guys.
It's really an honor to
be here, and as I alluded
to, Google really
powers a lot of what
we do without even a formalized
partnership in place,
just by the tools and technology
that you all have built.
But we're really excited
to hopefully build
something even more powerful
with you all and, to the extent
that anyone is interested,
please just email me.
We'd love to, whether it's going
to be a case study or even just
a Guinea pig for new things
that you guys are developing,
because we have a team that's
really eager to work with folks
like you all to bring more
successful and outcomes-driven
education to people
around the world.
JESSE MICHELS: We
have some books
as well if you want to stick
around and pick those up.
Everybody, please give a
round of applause for Adam.
Thank you so much.
ADAM BRAUN: Thank you guy.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSE MICHELS: Appreciate it.